let's go to headlines number one the the
esteemed Alexandra o kzr Cortez the
esteemed scholar has a theory as to why
violent crime is on the rise and here's
here's her theory so why is this uptick
in crime happening well let's think
about it do we think this has to do with
the fact that there's record
unemployment in the United States right
now the fact that people are at a level
of economic desperation that we have not
seen since the Great Recession maybe
this has to do with the fact that people
aren't paying their rent and are scared
to pay their rent and so they go out and
they need to feed their child and they
don't have money so you maybe have to
you're they're put in a position where
they feel like they either need to
shoplift some bread or go hungry that
night shoplifting bread sure you know
except the problem is that the crimes on
the rise are not bread thefts I'm not
aware of any statistic about bread being
stolen at a higher rate than usual I'm
not I'm not aware of that happening no
the crimes that are on the rise are
crimes like this the community is up in
arms as you might imagine the overs is
tragic and senseless murder of a 22
month old I just got the update from the
New York City Police Department they
tell me this little boy it was
identified as Gisele Gardner he lived
here in Brooklyn in Brownsville however
he was at a cookout with family members
here on Madison Street overnight it was
around 11:30 and you can see this
morning that little boy's stroller still
on the sidewalk police telling me he was
sitting there when two men walked up and
just started firing into the crowd that
little boy was shot in the stomach he
was rushed to an area hospital where
doctors could not save him from that
gunshot wound to the stomach three other
people here at this cookout were also
wounded three adult men they are
expected to be ok witnesses telling me
that they saw these suspects sprint away
possibly into a waiting vehicle on
Marcus Garvey Boulevard this was just a
one of
35 people shot over this weekend and
clearly people in the community are
incensed two years old less than two
actually a baby shot in the stomach
killed at a barbecue with his family
added to the list of children very young
children in many cases who've been
murdered in our cities over the last few
weeks and let's be clear about about
what AOC is doing here because she is
looking to distract from from from this
by dressing this kind of crime up as you
know a downtrodden person stealing bread
now she wasn't talking specifically
about this case when she said that but
she was justifying the rise in crime and
the rise in crime has been a rise in
this kind of crime and she knows that it
has been a rise in violent crime against
often innocent children or other members
of the community and usually the black
community that's the crime we're dealing
with and she's trying to justify it
number two there were protests at
speaking of justifying crimes there were
protests in Detroit over the weekend of
our man named Akeem Littleton who was
shot and killed by police protesters
were as as this NBC's headline says
demanding justice here's some footage of
that peaceful protest of people who just
want nothing but justice in the world
watch
[Applause]
so peaceful so soapy actually several
cops were assaulted during that peaceful
protests because you know they these
protesters were so distraught over a
keen little team that they had no choice
but to assault police officers
the only problem which isn't really a
problem for the protesters who couldn't
care less about the truth obviously but
still the issue here is that despite the
testimony of eyewitnesses who say the
hakim was was gunned down unarmed you
know despite that he was actually in
reality pulling a gun and firing it at
police officers here's the video of that
altercation this weekend parts of
Detroit on edge as protesters demand
justice for Hakim Littleton the 20 year
old shot and killed by police Friday
afternoon the outrage set off after
claims on social media
accusing Detroit Police of killing an
unarmed man authorities responded by
releasing - and body cam footage showing
members of the police gang squad
approaching and arresting Darnell
Sylvester wanted on a federal drug
warrant while he complies I thoughti say
Littleton standing nearby appears to
pull out a weapon witness at the same
told investigators that mr. Wilton
stated I'm not going to say exactly this
but basically that you're not going to
take
this body cam footage appears to show
Littleton shooting at an officer and
missing before police returned fire the
police chief says he released the videos
to set the record straight
but even after these images became
public protesters still want answers
[Music]
Kathy Park NBC News
so cops were making an arrest of someone
else Akeem was there decided to take the
opportunity to try and execute a cop you
can clearly see him pulling a gun and
firing and then he was shot and killed
so the you know thank God the police
were able to take him down before any of
before he was able to successfully
murder any of them he's the bad guy here
cut-and-dry you know it's it's it's sad
that he decided to throw his own life
away hit a fool that he made that choice
but there's no outrage here there's no
injustice and once again you know it's
it just feels hopeless after well
because this doesn't matter either
I mean you if you were dealing with
rational people and there was a protest
over a police shooting and then a video
came out proving that the person who was
shot was shooting at police that would
be the end of it and the protesters if
they were rational people and also maybe
not even being rational isn't even the
issue if they were really concerned
about police brutality if that was
actually the concern then they would say
okay you know we got this one wrong
sorry to the police officers you word
you know you're defending yourselves
obviously thank you for keeping our
community safe we'll go home people who
were really concerned about police
brutality that's how they would respond
but these protesters of course don't
care about police brutality at all it's
got nothing to do with it
for a lot of them it's just an excuse a
you know a forum for wreaking
destruction and all of that and then we
know for BLM and and the leaders of this
movement they've got a lot of a lot on
their plate agenda wise in police
brutality has almost nothing to do with
any of it number three let's go over to
the
UK to talk about soccer which which you
know it's a great activity for people
who don't like sports Crystal Palace
swinger Wilfried Zaha I don't know what
any of those words mean a winger sounds
like something you'd order at Applebee's
I don't know but anyways aha recently
posted online some screenshots of racist
messages that he received from someone
and they are certainly very racist and
objectionable messages the police got
involved when tracked down the source of
these messages
turns out the culprit was a 12 year old
boy a 12 year old who's sending me
messages to a grown man a soccer player
now in a sane world the story ends there
the boy's parents deal with his bad
behavior maybe ground him take away his
videogames you know something like that
and the rest of the world moves on but
we don't live in such a world so instead
the police arrested the 12 year old boy
for the bad things he wrote online and
nobody seems to have any problem with
this either the police department issued
a statement saying the twelve-year-old
arrested in connection with racist
social media messages sent to a
footballer has been has been released
under investigation while our inquiries
continue racism has no place in our
society and we're attempting to contact
the footballer to obtain a statement so
they're still investigating what is
there to investigate it was a 12 year
old saying bad stuff
Zhaan's Saha also is not stepping in he
you know this is where if it were me I
would step in and say hey yo okay guys
we don't need to a rat I didn't realize
as a twelve-year-old listen we don't
need to arrest prepubescent children for
saying bad things let's let's let's just
let's let's calm down okay that's not
what AHA saying he's fully on board
here's his statement he says very
disappointed we didn't get a better
result yesterday but I wanted to come on
here to thank all of you for your
messages and support all would also like
to thank the West Midlands Police for
their swift action and making an arrest
people need to understand that whatever
your age your behavior and your words
come with consequences and you cannot
hide behind social media so he's fully
on board with with with arresting a 12
year old Hodgson is the manager of the
soccer team he says it's very saddening
on the day of a game that a player wakes
up to this cowardly and despair
you'll abuse I think it's right that
people are made aware of it I don't
think this is something we should keep
quiet about there is literally no excuse
there is no excuse at all
cowardly despicable actions you're
talking about a 12 year old here and
then doing a cursory glance online
looking at the comments on Sky News the
Sky News post about this the comments
are probably 90% in favor of the arrest
of a 12 year old with the caveat that
many of them are saying the parents also
should be arrested that's their problem
with this it's not the bait arrest of
the 12 year old for stuff that he wrote
online for mean comments he made to a to
a grown man it's said they didn't also
arrest the parents for it as well
number four the head writer for Tucker
Carlson show Blake Neff has resigned
after someone told the media that he
Neff has been posting anonymously on a
message board for years now and many of
us posts are racist and sexist the media
has been having a field day with this of
course and fox news came out forcefully
to condemn Neff here's what they said we
want to make abundantly clear that fox
news media strongly condemns this
horrific racist misogynistic and
homophobic behavior Neffs abhorrent
conduct was never divulged to the show
until Friday at which point we swiftly
accepted his resignation make no mistake
actions such as this cannot be and will
not be tolerated at any time in any part
of our workforce now the interesting
thing is that the folks over at NBC have
been spiking the football over this but
NBC has just promoted joy Reed who is a
woman who on her own blog under her own
name for years posted stuff that was in
line with a lot of the things this guy
was writing particularly when it comes
to you know her comments about
homosexuals and again she was doing that
under her own name proudly for years and
rather than accept responsibility she
claimed that she'd been hacked when all
this was found out but NBC not only does
NBC not condemn and fire her but
actually they're promoting her they're
giving her more airtime and herein lies
another crucial distinction between the
left and right
Fox is tripping all over itself
condemning oh it's horrific unimaginable
terrible he's gone we're getting rid of
him while NBC grants a larger platform
to their own offender it's and let me
just say also by the way horrific is a
word that more accurately describes say
the actions of a serial killer or a
school shooter or someone like that that
that's a word you pull out when it when
when something like that happens
horrific horrific actions trolling a
message board anonymously is not
horrific might be bad a might be
objectionable but yeah I really think we
should reserve a word like horrific for
actually horrific like something that
when you hear about it you are actually
horrified like you it takes your breath
away it's so horrifying
that's what horrific is I never been
aware of any comment on a message board
that could possibly rise to that level
but you know that's just me
number five finally we must pause to
honor this hero watch you take a picture
of me that make you feel better why
don't you get a life that's going around
taking pictures the mayor's asked us all
to wear masks and look at you not
wearing a mask
Oh political it's unbelievable now you
have accosted me in this store that I
got the wear of man if you're gonna keep
this up maybe we'll get the police
department you call nine nine one then
yeah I'm out of a tree now you're the
monkey that has it pay off tracking
those knuckles no she's not admire her
do I remove them evolution
why don't you go back to where you are
you burning crosses are you burning
crosses no you're the idiot doing my
shopping you're unbelievable
good luck with the virus good luck with
the virus your whole family tree is
getting up at its roots that that man we
need to build a statue to that man and
guard it we need to put post armed
guards around the statue 24/7 so that no
harm comes to the Statue but I and this
is not I think we should be clear you
know we've seen a lot of these videos
with involving people wearing masks or
not wearing masks and everything and
sometimes they're people who go in to
places without the masks on they're the
ones filming and they're trying to make
a scene or a statement of it which i
think is really stupid this is a guy
he's not looking he's looking for any
attention he wasn't making a statement
or making a scene he just yeah he had he
had the shopping list from his wife in
his hand you could see there and he was
just going in to buy some stuff and he
wanted to go go about his day he wasn't
bothering anybody wasn't hurting anybody
if you're worried that he's gonna spread
a disease to you then just keep walking
go to a different aisle avoid him if
you're really scared on you don't
surround him and get within six feet and
start shouting at him get into a
shouting match that's that's not what
you would do if you're really worried
that someone's gonna spread a disease to
you but I thought he handled that just
every every part of the way he handled
that was great and that is just that's a
classic dad right there okay he's got
the t-shirt tucked in the jorts the
glorious beer gut it's got the white
shoes the socks pulled up you know
shopping list from his wife had on okay
that is that is a dead and you don't
tangle you don't tangle with a classic
dad some of these New Age dads maybe you
could you could get away with that but
the
not this dead those ladies they should
have known that okay this is not go pick
on someone else and you know what else
is gonna happen I guarantee this okay
that guy went home and either didn't
mention this event at all to his wife or
told her about it in about three minutes
and then went outside to mow the grass
and that was it and he stopped thinking
about it
meanwhile those women I guarantee you
they went home to their tortured
husbands and and told them this story in
about a three hour long saga you know
the story taking a hundred times longer
than the actual event itself that it's
meant to describe and and are still
talking called all their friends and
they're gonna be telic talking about it
at Thanksgiving guaranteed but then
again as a man if you choose to marry a
woman like that I guess you really bring
it on yourself this video is sponsored
by blink sale the revolutionary
invoicing software for contractors and
small businesses spend less time billing
and more time making bank with blink
sale get a free trial at the link in the
video description